- I'm Neil.
- I'm Garrett.
I've seen Star Wars.
- I have not seen Star Wars.
- And I want to talk
about it in front of Neil.
- Yeah.
- But Neil is telling me I can't.
- Today we're gonna decide
what National Star Wars Spoiler Day is.
(upbeat music)
- [Garrett] When do you think
it's OK to spoil Star Wars?
- Um, two weeks after the release.
- Probably when the
movie is out of theaters.
- At least seven days, at least a week.
- One seven day, standard calendar week.
- Seven days.
- If you don't want to hear the spoilers,
you should see it opening weekend.
- I think 2016 is fair game.
- I would say January
first it's open season.
- One year, a full year.
- In a month.
- Never, get away from me.
- I don't think it's ever cool
to just say the end of a movie.
- Thank you.
- Look around, you know,
be aware of your surroundings.
Just don't be a dick about it.
- Don't be a dick.
- Personally I don't really
care about Star Wars.
All I want to know is if
the black guy dies or not.
- I think after a week you can
you can talk about it freely,
but if someone asks you
to stop talking about it,
you should still stop talking about it.
- I don't think you need to spoil it.
Like so many people have seen it,
you can just talk about it
with people who've seen it.
Like I don't think you need to
tweet what happens during it.
- If someone hears people
talking about Star Wars,
and they haven't seen it,
it's like their responsibility
to get out of the conversation.
- Should I feel bad for
not having seen it yet?
- Yeah, you should.
- No, but if you're gonna
bitch about spoilers,
you gotta go see it, Neil.
- I'm trying, it's hard to get tickets.
- It kind of sounds like
you're, like, making excuses.
You need to like just go see it
so that everyone can talk about it.
It's not fair to not do it
if you're not going to prioritize it.
- What if I told you I was waiting
to see it with my family, with my parents?
(Garrett laughs)
- Star Wars is a unique thing.
A lot of people have a very deep
family connection to the movie.
So even though it is the
biggest release of all time,
it is realistic that people are waiting
for their family to see it at Christmas.
- I think it scales on cultural impact,
and the cultural impact
is so great of Star Wars
that it pushes everything back.
- But cultural impact means
everyone sees it the first weekend.
If you don't, you're in trouble.
- I think that the Darth Vader twist
at the end of Empire Strikes Back,
that is something that can
never be replicated again.
I think maybe Sixth Sense is maybe
the last one that we as
a culture will ever get
to experience because of
the way the internet works.
We're just not willing to allow
people's surprises anymore.
- OK, so we got a lot of answers.
- We talked to a lot of people.
We calculated it out.
- National Star Wars Spoilers Day is
January first, 2016.
(upbeat music)